league of legends world finals happened
over the weekend and to be honest with
you it was the best we've ever seen
returning korean champs damon gaming
came within inches of getting the title
that everyone expected them to get but
edg clearly hadn't read the script what
followed was easily the biggest upset
slash anime
fairy tale ending that we've ever seen
at worlds
look if you want to see more league
content on this channel it's pretty
simple you got to like this video you
got to subscribe to the channel you got
to leave a comment down below that's the
only way that i can convince the
higher-ups that we should be doing more
league content so help me out okay all
right so like many past finals over the
years this year was a battle between the
two undisputed best regions in league of
legends korea's lck and china's lpl all
right moving on spoiler alert edg one
world 2021 there you go
it's out there now i guess but before we
talk about them we need to talk about
the team that was expected to win this
year's worlds down one gaming from the
moment they lifted the trophy at last
year's worlds the korean kings were the
favorites to win in 2021 and that's not
just my opinion they were the bookies
favorites the smart money was on them to
win this year's tournament a whole year
ago after world's last year dan one
would go on to comfortably win their
domestic kesper cup as well as both the
spring and summer lck splits they didn't
take their foot off the gas at all they
absolutely flawed it in fact the only
real blip on the way to worlds this year
came at msi when they were upset by
china's rng without summoners is
incredibly vulnerable they're setting up
for a three-man play here flash zenith
blade is beautiful the follow-up is
there and showmaker is gone gone gone
but xiaohu on the flank he wants to go
who's ready to go and they're already
going go and gone show maker is down
they're gonna pick up the second on the
canyon they'll continue pushing forward
dom juan is not long for this world
everybody is dropping dead right in
front of our eyes rng they're on the
nexus don juan has no ability to stop
this it's game over to be the best you
gotta beat the best and rng take down
the world champs to become your msi
champions of 2021.
suddenly there were a few creeping
doubts about damn one sure they were
still incredibly strong khan canyon
showmaker ghost beryl these were last
year's world champions already legends
of the game they weren't suddenly bad
but had china caught up to them well
over in the lpl edg had surprised a lot
of people by becoming summer split
champions over fun plus phoenix can he
make the impossible possible scout
trying to move on in tien jumps into the
pit but he's already gone down the
barrel taken by edg and they look for
the fight as well doing b will fall in
the midst of enemies and edg push
forward 1462
days since the last time the edg won a
finals the faithful are rewarded again
what matters most is how well you walk
through the fire and this blaze has been
extinguished so going into worlds in
october there were a couple of different
narratives floating around lck fans
maintained that korea was still on top
dan 1 had won last year's worlds they
dominated korea all year and come a
close second at msi those who worship at
the church of lpl wanted everyone to
know that china was back on top that
last year was just a blip and the
chinese victories of 2018 and 2019 were
about to continue now edg status as one
of the tournament favorites had waved a
little bit after finishing second in
their group to skt and some people saw
them as underdogs going into the
quarter-finals versus rng now to give
this all a little bit of historical
context it's important to remember that
when it comes to worlds edg has always
been horrendously down bad despite some
great rosters over the years that have
dominated the lpl in the five years
they've attended worlds they'd never
made it past quarter-finals they just
collapsed like a
flat in a cupboard but a closely fought
3-2 series saw them take down this
year's msi champions and when they did
exactly the same thing to gen g in
semi-finals people didn't know what to
think this was uncharted territory for
everyone including edg fans i mean sure
they got to the final but they've done
it in perhaps the most scuffed way
possible a second place finish in groups
into two three two series
they look good but you couldn't call it
dominant meanwhile on the other side of
the bracket dam one breezed past mad
lines but dropped two games to a surging
t1 in a closely fought series which saw
faker denied his fourth world title
damon had done it they got to the final
to where everyone thought they would be
even after a slight scare coming into
this game a lot of people have kind of
written edg off sure they look good but
this was damn one this was the korean
powerhouse looking for their second
title and a chance to start a dynasty
also now's a good chance to mention dan
one's top laner khan he's simply a
legend of the game and this tournament
was his last dance his last shot at
getting that elusive world title before
retiring after that players like canyon
and show maker who have been in the
discussion for best player on the planet
and it was kind of difficult to not side
with dan one for this series i think
it's going to be a 3-0 for damon i think
damon's play style is fantastic i think
t1 was able to kind of capitalize on a
little bit because of how flexible they
were in draft with things like lissandra
poppy these kind of target picks zillion
to actually win out games by
neutralizing damon's early game and
winning out in mid to late game through
neutral objectives but i think chance
for the lpl no chance i think eg don't
have the flexibility that t1 did and i
think damon is just going to run away
with this series all right azalea
where's your head at i mean i'm on the
dominant side i think it's almost
impossible not to be you know i do think
that canyon is such a difference maker
here i think he he really is too much
for jj but i do think that edg can team
fight with domwan i think that they will
be able to get a game i you know i have
it 3-1 but i think if edg can have a
strong early game they can match in the
5v5 i just think they're not as
well-rounded but if the script said that
it was supposed to be a 3-0 stomp for
damn one nobody gave edg a copy of that
before game one it's burning down for
now in goes jj though into the back side
it's flash out immediately from ghost
has the jargon out of position but still
able to grab the kill and look at all of
that healing as well he's gonna get
resurrected from the chrono shift and
now it's done on kia that are on the run
canyon is not rooted just yet but khan
is just dead down goes canyon as well
and there is the rift herald can bring
them back to life in goes jj they just
explode show maker he is so important
for their team fight and he goes golden
as well he's got the sterics he's got
the chrono ship it's an immortal jarvan
trying to win the team fight and edg
have lost no one in goes barrel once
again but it's going to be a sacrifice
and don juan kia are left with corpses
on the rift the nexus turrets are
falling and for a series that so many
predicted was a 3-0 yes it might be but
it's not going to be for darwin gear
edward gaming absolutely wiping the
floor with our former world champions
the script got back on track though in
game two with an absolute master class
from canyon and khan honestly khan's
graves made me want to just play graves
for like five hours straight
in fact i might do that tonight game
three saw down one claw victory from a
goal deficit thanks to some expertly
played team fights and showmaker just
abusing silas to the max so where are we
now well it's 2-1 to the current world
champions sure dam 1 had had a little
bit of a shaky start but you'd be crazy
not to back them at this point and just
ignore the teams for a second history
itself said the next game and the series
itself should go to damn one there had
only ever been a single world's final up
to this point that had gone to five
games you were statistically trolling if
you thought this one was but as we all
found out this wasn't a day for logic
yeah this could be the pick up the
minion wave turns up in the nick of time
but ghost could be the one to go down
and he absolutely is the heartbreaker
comes in now jj in a bit of trouble he
just gets himself over the wall canyon
explodes as well as nami's turned into a
fish finger rumors of the lpo's demise
have been greatly exaggerated
this year my friends edg will just put a
stomp down on game number four push us
to silver scrapes push us to that game
five alice
right it's difficult to explain the
gravity of this moment it's 2-2 in a
world's final that's only ever happened
twice in league's 11 year history like
holy [ __ ] not only that damn one had
only lost two games on their way to the
final so it seemed unthinkable that
they'd lose three in one series but the
craziness and silver scrapes that was
erupting on western twitter was nothing
compared to the real-life scenes from
china as edg headed into game five
[Applause]
and as it turns out it might have been
the best game in the entire series it
was a game of inches until a single pick
opened it up for edg at the 23-minute
mark force
yeah he's so far forward has to flash
out the scan of the week is good but
it's not good enough the slicing
maelstrom comes in and now khan trying
to take down canyon there's a collateral
damage finally he gets it done and he's
not done yet jj taking a lot of damage
khan will fall down ghost is still alive
doing a fair bit of work but beryl he's
in the middle of four people and edg
will wipe them off the map it's just a
lonely ziggs and edg have full control
now most teams in the world who were
playing against an edg in this position
in this kind of form would roll over
they'd probably just sit back and hope
that edg made a mistake but this was
damn one we're talking about with their
backs against the wall they pulled off
the single cheekiest two-man baron in
the history of the game and despite
edg's presence on the map they didn't
have a clue wait wait wait the two-man
baron is going on right now edg have no
idea yeah and uh donald kid can throw
down the ultimate from the ziggs the
barons still going down
this is the world finals and they're
sneaking with two people 3k left canyon
going down burning
mako can he actually get awarded to this
pit he does and he gets the bad news it
is taken by khan there was no smite
because kelly had to use it to stay
alive i mean honestly everyone lost
their [ __ ] minds at that point damon
had no right doing that but they refused
to simply bleed out in a slow death to
edg but after 40 minutes 24 kills two
barons five dragons and an elder dragon
the unthinkable finally became a reality
there is one turret between edg and
history right now is viper dash is
forward showmaker goes golden but it's
not going to keep him alive mako is
going to be the sacrificial left but
it's a double kill already for flandre
lightning rushing his way out of this
one and now the nexus is exposed on one
kia are limping and edg at the man
advantage the nexus will go down and
against all odds
edg will be your 2021 world champions
they've done it they've actually done it
the lpl is back on top the mad lads
actually did it after first appearing at
worlds in 2014 and failing to get past
quarterfinals at each of the five times
they attended they show up in 2021 and
win the whole thing and if you had any
doubt about what this meant to the
long-suffering edg fans the videos
coming out of china said it all
what was great about edg this world was
that they clearly improved as the
tournament went on the edg that came
second in their group after dropping a
game to north america's hundred thieves
no offense probably couldn't have beaten
damn one but they learnt from that and
then they played back to back best of
five series in quarters and semis that
both went to a game five edg played 16
games on their way to the final that's a
lot of practice as exhausting as that is
that might have been what gave them the
edge when they faced off against a
seemingly invincible down one not always
but usually world's finals are a pretty
one-sided affair this game was anything
but it was messy it was scrappy it could
have gone either way as one redditor
pointed out edg's 13 wins and eight
losses during the tournament was the
lowest win rate for a world's winner in
the tournament's history and perhaps the
five-game slugfest the anime storylines
and the upset ending help contribute to
this year's ridiculous viewing figures
worlds 2021 beat its personal record
from two years ago for peak viewership
clocking in at over 4 million peak
viewers and that's excluding any viewers
from china which i'm sure you can
imagine with edg winning a final that
went all the way to five games were
probably insane the headline is
league's doing all right next year we'll
have crowds next year we'll have fresh
teams and faces to go alongside the
veterans whose storylines have kept us
gripped for the better part of a decade
world is over it was sick but now let's
get those juicy off-season rumors
flowing shall we i really hope yoga
doesn't go to team liquid
he's probably gonna go isn't he
when it comes to worlds edg has always
been horrendously down bad
i don't know if that sounds right coming
out of my mouth but
i'm like horrendously down that
isn't like david attenborough like edgy
has always been horrendously down bad
that was a really freaking good
impression that actually shocked me
here we are at worlds 2021